welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar amplifying human
ingenuity with intelligent technology it
is presented by Claudia murti principal
solutions specialist for data and AI at
Microsoft my name is Judy O'Rourke and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth lab routes is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before I begin I would like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now about further ado please
join me in welcoming Claudio Bertie I
will now turn the presentation over to
him hello everyone
thank you for having me so I will
welcome you to the first section about
doing explore and a little bit explain
why data analytics and artificial
intelligence are coming so so very
important at the moment because we want
to drove I'm going to have data-driven
insights and action in our world where
we are working on so if I go through
artificial intelligence and analytics
promise really really an an important
topic that is in every component so
because with the date that we want to
know what happens so we call them repo
as we know everyone what did it happen
to make it interactive dashboards but
now the future wants to know what should
I do
or at least what should I do when when
you have to have recommendations of
automation based on your data it's a
little bit explaining when you are
considering the weather forecast and
when you know when I have to get an
umbrella with me and when should I take
it so and then it's also with the
data-driven decision that accelerates
the all digital transformation where we
are working on so cloud data
intelligence this is all words that are
very common in our world we are working
on but when we go back and say for years
we had to learn to use the technology
but today AI helps us to the technology
to learn from us and our data and maybe
as well to discover new ways that be
helpful in our work so if we are going
back and the things where the
capabilities are then we have seen come
about the past few years we will see
that there is a huge new generation
coming up and that is the generation
where we can use a technology like AI
but by now because now we say
democratizing artificial intelligence
the technology is already here and we
can use it and help to transform our
business but our business based in the
pharmaceutical industry as an example is
they need more information for a
presence medication or maybe they have
difficulties to bring the drug to market
or to reduce the time to market and as
well there is a lot of challenges in
cost there are both people are not
taking their medication
how we can support this this healthcare
or does from a through this challenges
we
the healthcare industry is focusing on
and in order to deliver the scheme
paratus I think that our four topics
that are really interesting for the
pharmaceutical one is the innovation
fostered drug discovery clinical trial
efficiency but as well the regulatory
compliance and innovation for new
treatment and research and development
are some of the basics that is really
really crucial but when we are talking
about artificial intelligence is
important that we have to know that it
really supports the principles about
fair accountable transparent and ethical
so it's also to our command but to
achieve more but always to respect and
to assist humanity and that it's very
important when we developing or when we
starting our journey with artificial
intelligence because transforming in
healthcare is important to improving
really well being around the world and
the patient's as well to support them so
when we're talking about all the example
with AI and and then information that we
get is is all about as well the machine
learning part and if I taking an example
is if you take a wheel of a blood
example and if you hold that in your
hands you have a 1 million of t-cells
and how you get sequencing of the DNA is
the huge amount of this information you
can only transcript or extract the
information using machine learning that
helps as well - for the immune system to
identify or unlock diagnostics and as
well to find new disease to treat new
disease in in this environment so and
this information will be only possible
with machine learning and the huge
compute power that supports that process
but both of them I think is something
that helps to go really on a patient
centric approach because we have there's
different different capabilities that
can support treatments clinical trials
or as well the collaboration research
because based of them we also in the
connected world that we can help the
base as well the name of Internet of
Things have they're really really
end-to-end process who supports the data
from collecting from the device over to
transform it as well analyze it and
dashboarding it using technology who is
today available but this are really how
industry challenges and we go back and I
think one of the of the main topics is
really that we have this challenge as
more people long lifespans more chronic
disease but the strains budget I think
this are the challenges that the
healthcare industry is addressed and
actually but what we want to achieve is
really do have us know that to transfer
the sick care system code that we have
for everyone and organization quick and
easy access to the right information and
this should be where technology like
artificial intelligence machine learning
and and other topics could support the
healthcare industry and the important
thing as say when we as a Microsoft
offer this technology we are talking
about a platform company so we provide
end-to-end technology that our partners
or
solution provider can build powerful
technology using our services and when
we say empowering health transformation
then we have some four pillars so one we
say of course in the patient in the
middle and empowered care teams and
clinical operational effectiveness and
transform the care continuum that means
using really addressing and using
technology like Internet of Things where
we can provide insights connecting
devices but of course there are as well
as some modern challenges and I think
the data constraints they're where we
have all the data repositories and as
well process but with the old thinking
that we can as well use this data and
and Richard we have here as well when we
go in another example in a way it's all
about the data is about advanced
analytics in health that will help
really on real-time but as well to use
think better things and that are the two
main topics that we can address with our
technology as well to help on different
solution as example when we say
optimization of clinical and operational
effectiveness so work order recommend
the treatments options based on
successful outcomes for similar patients
as an example where we go to health
population is how our platform after
intelligence to take the data out or as
well to prevent hospitalization another
example is what is how we can identify
which treatments have been most
effectiveness for patient they fast
specific demographics so this goes
really in personalized medication and
one of the important thing is of course
the quality control it has to be
that is most useful when he can give you
an image picture but what should I do
what we can what we can maybe help other
departments as well to analyze the data
and really fast to support them all the
departments as well mostly from
organizational point of view and office
mitigation risk is always about
standards of care and the compliance to
have it always in front and to respect
the data privacy well and again as I
think move towards a patient centric
approach to health is always like really
to be to support like systems of
insights and system of engagement that
means really to to move forwards to
connect it for the swell to supportive
healthcare and it could be like clinical
decision supports that we hear all the
time
so when we say engage patient that we
can summarize a little bit from all the
technology that they are available today
is really provide patients with more
information about medications they are
taking to help them make most of the
treatments then research team I think
one of the challenges is always when
there were a lot of different research
crew working together I think
collaboration and the Naval
collaboration across organizations of
regional boundaries because that's
important thing that they can share
their insights optimize clinical and
operational effectiveness I think
leverage data with advanced analytics
and all that information that we can use
and as well to give researcher foster
insights and at least transformation of
health is really that we can say lower
two markets with more active named
effective efficient efficient operations
and part by machine learning because
this is something that really helps to
process a large amount of data and
everything but Microsoft is really
empowering in the Health Organization is
really well scalable and if the cloud
capabilities and highly secure and
compliant and one thing that is always
in our mind using with our Microsoft AI
platform that we call in different age
like services we have infrastructure we
have all the tools set we explaining a
little bit to playing Lego but is really
to to use different services is always
about to have the high PA that I think
the the certification and as well to be
compliant and to support all regulatory
standards who are relevant for every
player in the healthcare industry based
on that is as a last point and it's
really important not only to have happy
patients with as well that we have a
collaboration that can use connected
device transformed data support
personalized treatment and remote
monitoring effective in clinical trials
all that data that we collect that we
can support the patient for his journey
during his journey that we can then
address the right medication but as well
to support him with the right
information means that we can reduce
this is pain and and support during the
political decision support when research
does by working together and behalf this
and to end process where we support with
our technology and last but not least I
would say thank you for having a huge
view about the capabilities and what we
have and happy to answer your question
if you want to know more about it thank
you Thank You Claudia for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May 14 2019
and as a final reminder our speaker will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we will see
you next time goodbye